so
how do you detect you started to talk
about it but
can we linger on it how do you detect
phosphine
on a far away thing rocky thing rocky
planet
what uh what is uh spectroscopy
what is this molecular fingerprint what
does it look like
you've kind of mentioned the wave but
what do we what are we supposed to think
about
what are the tools what are the
uncertainties all those kinds of things
so the the path can go this way you've
got light
kind of pure light you can crack that
light open
with a prism or a spectroscope or water
and make a rainbow that rainbows
all the colors and all the invisible
colors the ultraviolet the infrared
and if that light was truly pure you
could consider that rainbow to just
cover continuously all of these colors
but if that light goes through a gas
we may not see that gas we certainly
cannot see the molecules within that gas
but those molecules will steal absorb
some of
that light some but not all each
molecule absorbs only very specific
colors of that rainbow and so if you
know for example
that shade of green can only be absorbed
by methane
then you can watch as a planet passes in
front of a star
the planet is too far away you can't see
it and it has an atmosphere
that atmosphere is far too small you
definitely can't see it
but the sunlight will go through that
atmosphere and if that atmosphere is
methane
then on the other side that shade of
blue i can't run if i said blue
green but that color will be missing
because
methane took it and so with phosphene
it's the same thing
it has specific colors 16.8 billion
colors that it absorbs it and nothing
else
does and so if you can find them and
notice them missing
from the light of a star that went
through a planet's atmosphere
then you'll know that atmosphere
contains the molecule
how cool is that that's incredible so
you can have this
fingerprint within the space of colors
and there's a lot of molecules and i
mean i would i wonder
that's a question of like how much
overlap there is how how
close can you get to the actual
fingerprint like
can phosphine unlock the iphone with its
uh lights on
he says 16.8 billion so
presumably this rainbow is descritized
into little segments somehow exactly how
many total are there how
how how a lot is 16.8 billion
it's a lot you we don't have the
instruments to
break these break any light into this
many tiny segments
and so with the instruments we do have
there's huge amounts of overlap
methane as an example a lot of the ways
it's detectable is because the carbon
and the hydrogens they vibrate with one
another they move they interact
but every other hydrocarbon acetylene
isoprene has carbon and hydrogens
also vibrating and rotating and so it's
actually very hard to tell them apart
at low resolutions and our instruments
can't really cope with distinguishing
between molecules particularly well
but in an ideal world if we had infinite
resolution then yes
every molecule spectral features will be
unique
yeah like almost to uni like it would be
too trivial
at the quantum level at our level
uh there's huge overlap yeah but then
you can start to then
what try to disambiguate like what the
mis
the fact that certain colors are missing
what does that mean and hopefully
they're missing a certain kind of
pattern where you can say with some kind
of probability that it's this gas not
this gas
or you're solving that gaseous puzzle
i got it okay we can go back to venus
actually and show that so
with this i mentioned those two
molecules that could be responsible for
that signal at the resolution that we
have
it was phosphene and so2 and
sulfur dioxide and at that resolution
could really be
one of the other but in that same
bandwidth so in the kind of the same
observations
there was another region where phosphine
does not absorb we know that
but so2 does so we just went unchecked
and there was no signal so we thought oh
then it must be phosphine and then we
submit to the paper
the rest is history my god uh
well yeah that's um beautifully told
is there uh so the telescopes we're
talking about are sitting on earth
what can it help solving this
fingerprint molecular fingerprint
problem if we do a flyby
does it help if we get closer and closer
or are telescopes pretty damn good
for this kind of uh puzzle solving
telescopes are pretty good but
the earth's atmosphere is a pain i mean
i'm very thankful for it um
but it does interrupt a lot of
measurements and a lot of
regions where phosphate would be active
they are not available
the earth is not transparent in those
wavelengths so being above the
atmosphere would make a huge difference
then proximity matters a lot less but
just
escaping the earth's atmosphere would be
wonderful but then it's really hard to
stay very stable
and if there is phosphate on venus
there's very little of it
in the clouds and so the signal is very
weak
and the telescopes we can use on earth
are
much bigger and much more stable so it's
a bit of a trade-off
so is it um
are you comfortable with this kind of
remote observation is it at all helpful
to uh strive for going over to venus and
like
grabbing a scoop of the atmosphere
or is remote observation really a
powerful tool
for this kind of job like the scoop is
not necessary
well a lot of people want to scoop i get
it
i get it that's my natural inclination
yet i don't want to scoop specifically
because if it is life
i want to know everything i can remotely
before i interfere
um so that's my i've got ethical reasons
against the scoop more than engineering
reasons against the scoop
but i have some engineering reasons
against the scoop scoop is not a
technical term but i feel like now it's
too late
thank you for going along with this it's
too late to take it back i appreciate it
we don't understand the clouds well
enough to plan the scoop
very well because it's not that
saturated like there's not that much
of it present no and the place is nasty
you know it's not it's not going to be
easy to build something that can
do the task reliably and can be trusted
the measurements can be trusted and then
pass that message on
so actually i'm for an orbiter i think
we should have orbiters around
every solar system body whose job is
just to learn about these places
i'm disappointed we haven't already got
an orbiter
around every single one of them a small
it can be a small satellite
screening data figuring out you know how
do the clouds move what's
in them how often is there lightning and
volcanic activity
what is the topography is it changing is
there a biosphere
actively doing things we should be
monitoring this from afar
and so i'm for uh over the atmosphere
hopefully around venus that would be
that would be my choice
okay so now recently venus is all
exciting about phosphine
and everything is there is there other
stuff maybe before we were looking at
venus or now
looking out into other solar systems
is there other promising exoplanets or
other planets within
the solar system that might have
phosphine
or might have other strong
biosignatures that we should be looking
for
like phosphine there's a few but
outside the solar system all are kind of
promising candidates
we know so little about them for most of
them we barely know their density
most of them we don't even know if they
have an atmosphere never mind
what that atmosphere might contain so
we're still very much the stage where
we have detected promising planets but
they're promising in that
they're about the right size about the
right density
they could have an atmosphere and
they're about the right
distance from their host star but that's
really all we know
near future telescopes will tell us much
more but
for now we're just guessing so you said
near future so
there's hope that there will be
telescopes that can see that far
enough to to determine if there's an
atmosphere and
perhaps even the contents of the
atmosphere absolutely jwst launching
later this year we'll be able to get
a very rough sense of the main
atmospheric constituents of
planets that could potentially be
habitable
and that's this here you know what's the
name of jwst the james webb space
telescope okay
and that's going to be out in space past
the atmosphere
yes is there something interesting to be
said about the engineering aspect of the
telescope
it's an incredible beast but it's a
beast of many
burdens so it's going to do
it's good see you are a poet
yeah i love it this is very eloquent
you're speaking to the audience which i
appreciate
uh so so yes it's a giant engineering
project
and uh is it orbiting something do you
know so it's going to be above the
atmosphere
um and it will be doing lots of
different astrophysics and so some of
its time
will be dedicated to exoplanets
but there's an entire astronomy field
fighting for time
before the cryogenic lifetime of the
um instrument and so when i was looking
for
the possibility of finding phosphine on
distant exoplanets i use jwst
as a way of checking with this
instrument that we will launch
later this year could we detect
phosphine on an oxygen poor planet
and there i put very much a hard stop
where
some of my simulations said yes you can
totally do it but it will take
a little under the cryogenic lifetime of
this machine
so then i had to go well that that's not
going to no one's going to dedicate all
of jwst
to look for my molecule that no one
cared about
so we're very much at that edge but
there'll be many other telescopes in the
coming decades
that will be able to tell us quite a lot
about the atmospheres of potentially
habitable planets
you